I can't wait forever I'm not that
patient I've got too many things to -
you're comfy like a sweater but when the
Sun comes out I won't be needing you
[Music]
you smile conceals a secret and it's a
sickly sweet but I can't see the point
of taking deeper and through a SAP
inside it's just so beautiful
[Music]
I
please
[Music]
your rides making me feel dizzy when you
quiz me on my childhood hit movie I'll
share with you if you so kindly cut me
so I can
[Music]
confuse straight on me but instead I
enjoy this view that tae-soo shallowly
nice
[Music]
breath waiting for what you disagree
would you only see them now right here's
where we both and to afraid
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my best pilots under my stress
but the past I can't see
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fighting us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm afraid to say the words you left a
stress
I'm expected to first you
[Music]
[Music]
see
[Music]
this is just the story of a girl who
sold her heart she needed to forget she
needed a fresh start
be careful what you say cuz she no
longer feels the same I can arise if it
stains my love
sorry for I watched to regain the time
she lost when days but like seconds
since both your paths crossed sorted for
us whether keeping out this cold weather
body heat keeps her about it
she likes to think she's clever solar
for our nickels are your worth for
yourself a cold and it all over her
heart felt it heavy and brittle so
before up key to regain her dignity so
tall in a box my true
this is just the story of a girl whose
soda hound now she's forgotten she's
gone a fresh start
be careful what you say cause she know
I'm gonna feel
[Music]
as yours
[Music]
left
[Music]
versus now first the frame this is just
the story of a girl who sewed her heart
now she's for countin she's got a fresh
start
[Music]
hey guys before we stop can we all just
appreciate how frickin good this picture
is that you're looking at
it's a by Nic Egorov I see you in the
chat how [ __ ] good is it they sent it
to me today and yeah it's exactly where
I wish I could be on my birthday so
thank you very very much they put a few
Easter eggs into so those of you who
have been around for a while might
notice some bits and bobs in the picture
anyway oh not this one this one you will
go back to that one in a second though
but hello welcome to the stream the
second of all the three birthday streams
that I will be doing I'm gonna say hi to
who I can see and then I guess we'll
start with the stream I don't need these
on my nose so hello Nikki obviously hey
man sighs hey and untwine we're hey
drained or hazel Milanovic hey if 196
times I give her the happy birthday hey
Michaels tannic hey did I already say
drained or well I'm saying it again if I
have set up hey unless we care Hey
yes mr. Brightside and hello everyone
else today is my actual birthday
so no confusion here it is my birthday
today and angry playing some Deborah
daylight I haven't played dead by
daylight in a long time and I am playing
it with some good friends so um I guess
I'll introduce you to them yeah
the yeah go now oh I just want to say as
well thank you to everyone who's been
sending me birthday messages throughout
the day I haven't managed to look at all
of them yet or respond to everyone but
thank you thank you like honestly it
means so much it's gotten so many nice
messages and yeah my um my step-brother
sent me a video of my little niece
singing happy birthday to me which was
her niece we just now it was cute so
wait one second music for dead by
daylight now because there are gonna be
a bunch of people chatting as well as
the game you guys are gonna have to be
very vocal about noise levels and where
they're like something's too quiet or
not and I will just mix it and I'm sure
we'll we'll figure out along the way
and just make sure my friends are ready
and I will introduced introduce them to
you guys they are if you didn't know the
friends I'm playing with Tom also known
as zero in the chats quite often I have
livestream with him before a few times
and I'm also playing with Amy
you guys know Amy you love Amy actually
I'm just gonna I'm gonna introduce them
to you and then they can say hello I was
so right
oh hello so yes say oh oh my gosh Eliseo
whoa oh my god thank you so much wow
what a waste
oh yeah if you didn't do that on purpose
let me know can I cancel never see
but thank you thank you so much oh my
god I see oh thank you so much is way
too way too generous um yeah let's get
through so Tom you guys know that I have
played with him before probably thank
Joe and say hi Tom and he streams as
well on Twitch and he also um he's a
dungeon master as well a very good one
[Music]
I've seen I've seen I enjoy its
entertaining and we've also got Amy with
us pick guys from the Queen streams she
is here today and then
oh sorry carry on carry on oh okay in
every turn you guys up there's anything
oh my me is anything I I go new mic in
it's a bit it's a bit quiet what about
now testing testing one two three
[Music]
[Laughter]
and we also have Jordan he has three
would be once before in the past a very
long time ago oh yeah that was so long
ago the evil within okay remember I was
just saying immediate food yes we got
pizza I played a horror game you sat
there and ate it was all good good time
and we have Braden and he he's fresh to
live streaming so be kind ah we have to
be kind to Braden because he's he's got
a mouth Inge
waitwait say say say hi brownie though I
wouldn't want to hear your wonderful
accent okay he's not gonna say much but
when he does there'll be no nuggets of
just gold absolute gold since I'm even
more upset that you've got a mouth
injury over here these nuggets of gold I
don't think he has a mouth injury I
think he's just making is he making it
yeah so sore painful nation and from
this you won't distract you will play
hee hee hee you absolutely are if you're
gonna make me jump just like it's just
like what I'm saying Resident Evil and
then we just get I'd hear like a plum
get a little job scared oh we've been
huh
a job jobs Union via we've been having
chats we've been we've been sent up so
we're waiting on you know God gasps okay
game time game on uh it's this sound
okay now can everyone hear my friends
the testing testing one two three all
right I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make
it misty because I'd like a lot I'd like
a lot of killer so I'm gonna try it to
make sure it's like a little bit more
balanced I'm gonna make sure I only pick
like one perk always we've chatted about
folks and stuff already I forgotten what
the goodbye my journey hey Danny eight
almost level eight and no check you out
Tom Tom Tom don't go what are the good
perks absolutely honestly I put all this
effort into full-on tutorial
so I would go for thank you for hosting
sorry it's okay one hole one hole drink
urban evasion gaben evasion they're done
alphabetically
separated into the purple and green ones
yes we'll make it which is one of our
last purple ones that's a good one okay
I've got him I've got two that I like a
lot I like a sprint press and I like
adrenaline anything that gets me to run
away fast okay okay and now I need to
get my awesome other deck the killer the
schnoz not the schnoz you could try
doesn't have a schnoz well if I've got
something protect emotional problems
what's everyone got for their items
I clicked stuff randomly by the lunch
box we got okay I can like as the killer
I can see you guys so you've got three
mud kits and a firecracker makes it
sound like I'm spying on you you just
you just in the background like I'm in
the same lobby as you right likes your
name Dryden which name your name does he
go by many names yes do tell
Dwight Fairfield I do call him and his
bags sometimes oh that's really nice
that's a really cute nickname
very good enemy it's right here Oh Oh
bomb right I got it I was just laughing
laughing laughs oh I live CEO another
donation everyone like and subscribe
please and wish it's wonderful human
being an amazing birthday thank you
thank you so much
happy birthday happy piggy
oh we've got so many salty lips so grace
tasty right it's like jerky oh yeah also
Amy sometimes when you're trying to fix
it generator you have to do like a skill
test oh yeah I did that yeah okay oh
this face Bob yeah because it makes a
noise before the school chair test comes
up yes Wow
yeah yeah just listen out for them like
I stuck him too before yeah oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god wait you
murder you
[Music]
wait who are you playing as you haven't
seen before so there's like quiet
killers and there's loud killers right
[Music]
where Oh God okay oh you're um I'm not
I'm not the only bad thing about being
on coal with the killers like you don't
want to give anything away we're talking
to Steve Harrington tasty dish of a man
Oh
tasty blood wait I'm sorry energy blasts
oh there's a lot of explosions across
the map oh hello
oh my god hello my god indeed just so
you guys know deca demolition ours
doesn't work she's wearing a mask so
that's why no steam terrifying or a
second ago just wait till I get my angry
face on what you mean your angry face
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow very impressive weapon I love your
face and your flowing locks suck up all
that blood tasty tasty blood I lost
every one of them now very sad
alright you have a fun time on that hook
okay
you have fun someone come save me as my
birthday I hate when you say that killer
but I'm just wandering around I don't
know where I am okay generator like I
haven't seen one generator the other way
from worm gay because he was there so
what you do when you're on the toilet
somebody [ __ ] up a generator
the generators how do I do that hello a
[ __ ] my anger is gonna run out in a
second I'm gonna run out angry are you
gonna be just south level no I'm just
tired
I'm Italian demon man now but I hear
someone who needs a bit of murdering
dududududu i can folk here somewhere
that's don't know any of the generators
got no five left to do it's in the
bottom left corner Oh every time I hit
one of you I get some blood to suck up
and it powers my rage if you're
struggling to coins in races you can
usually see the generators because
they've got lamps above them oh
[Music]
[Music]
absolutely lockers are just a bad idea
Oh excellent but I will definitely crush
you if I get the opportunity or missed
Oh young man [ __ ] these please please
return yes like I missed my mom's not
very sure okay the extra hits are hits
the ones and then also continues so when
you're on my back you can wiggle if you
wiggle for long enough you will get free
unfortunately for you that's a hook
right here
oh hey we must look up all that
delicious blood power my rage Oh
bollocks
it's coming it's coming it's going Alex
it's just blood over here Steve
Harrington no you can run away you don't
just stand still when you get stabbed oh
my goodness oh just all this blood
leaving behind enemies there's so much
of it I've got blood disease
unfortunately I'm glad you distracted in
guys
I feel like I should going get Braden
but I'm busy Braden stays on the hook
for too long he'll go into second mode
of death he has to start pressing
spacebar
hi well plus rainy has been [ __ ] up
here Jordan I think cuz I sacrificed
myself for you you should come and do
something for quite quite a while I'm
wiggling yeah I'm doing the spacebar
struggle so you only Ami's yeah Ivy's
got the same
can we hear it the Mantis is laughing
the I revealed my location this is high
when the kid is in the chat it's a
things guys unfortunately you're too far
away okay I've heard that one before
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're too far away guys really
scattered
I'm incredibly scared wait isn't there
hatch if the rest of them die there is
people oh oh
serious gonna happen Amy died yeah I
know
alive or is yeah I'm crawling around on
the floor it's it shows you in the
bottom I heard more struggle the faster
you get taken if you're on the hook and
you struggle that's a chance that you'll
save yourself
oh my sweet prince
if you die you have the opportunity to
spectate there's a button that allows
you to spectate in the bottom-left of
like I was just watching the stream
[Laughter]
I played all of this game on the toilets
[Laughter]
so that was fun someone goes on the hook
you've got you gotta go save them like
ASAP because it's kind of is the killer
you could just stand there and count
them but it's kind of a dick move and if
you if you can't then what's gonna
happen is all of the other people gonna
do generators right yeah
bloody el Camas wiping y'all out like a
bunch of slave slave that's alright I
had my killer game so that is only whoo
I also so I had one perk and a perk that
I had just so that you guys know for
future reference was called spies from
the shadow and any crows that you ran
past made a calling noise and like to
see where you were oh wait so even if I
snuck past them no if you sneak past
them it you're fine oh sorry that's
explains why you didn't come straight
for me like every time I went past one
yeah no you know there's any of you
sprint passing sauce about that Eliseo
is like patron of the stream right now
man I know I know hurry so generous very
generous if you decide out today
a present that you have could you just
send it back right he wants to he wants
to be killing - yeah like you guys if
you guys want to continue like getting
into the game before you go go back
that's fine I mean III do suck it killer
so she said any possible if someone else
killer then I think being here without
birth all right would you officer candy
I'm a left-hand side there's like a
little switch to spectator bun if you
take out twice it'll turn due to the
color instead okay maybe maybe needs to
be I'm ready
that's the one logic smart how do you
died I'm smart until you hit me and then
I just take away from that game maybe
it's don't stand still when someone
stabs you thought I was gonna be the
first to die was right he relied on
teamwork that didn't exist cooperated
but believing in you he died silent
death that's true so why I've learned
from that is if you get a partner hook
scream and then these guys might come
and save you hit run hit run on the hook
scream
we can sabotage the hooks yes so you can
sabotage them with a there's a perk that
lets you do it or with the repair kit
honestly it's a bit it's kind of like
it's a bit [ __ ] come back they come back
after like two minutes I think referral
is here bruh flower you made a notice me
and baby I love you miss you
she made it she put a notification you
didn't notice me senpai is this the
Brady who is behind the Instagram
account
Bradon a oh yes that is that brazen gta5
is free on the epic store now another
one Eliseo thank you so much
rip Braden that's what there's a killer
on the loose
okay I'm gonna run one perk again ready
when you are
wait oh so ties too thick after he's
done being the killer listen Nicki
alright that's a lot of teaching that
I've had to do for you guys to have any
idea what's going on this game actually
hooks it's like a step above they didn't
get one generator in the last game all
right
I had one perk on okay there are a
couple steps from here to sabotage and
hooks
it's so weird to hear my name spoken did
I go right oh my god I'm so smart I was
like dreams thanks to you guys my dreams
are such a beautiful I don't know I
thought I was ready I've just rained a
select repair recommendations are you
grant I'm going from the list like it's
just finding them it's alphabetical you
know your ABCs no see
but it's separated by rarity so the
purple ones alphabetical then the green
ones don't trust me it doesn't mean
anything to him since he doesn't notice
aspect that's a toughy that is that is a
[Music]
a breeze from Mexico I discovered your
channel thanks to that indie video game
the introduction so yeah if he appeared
in the introduction oh like it was
enough game who made that game I'm crazy
hey what is the power button as a hit as
a killer so it's right click or left
control but when you're when you're the
killer it shows up on the bottom of the
screen you know ah that's okay then I'd
help you with two killer that you've
picked but I guess you want to keep it
keep their secret forever
Fritz Cornelius Fritz Cornelius says
imagine getting killed by two in the
pink I'm gonna escape from two in the
pink become he may not know his ABCs but
he knows his piece that was me that was
the rest of the comments I listen yeah
thanks again
lies he was sitting on the toilet it's
okay everyone needs to go for a pee but
don't know I I can't read the rest of
the long comments sitting on the toilet
oh that's a flashback yes toilet always
got corrupt intervention that's a good
and so some of the oh are you the
[ __ ] stranger things killer oh cool I
haven't seen this one yeah I haven't
seen this one yet cool it's trying to
think it up puts but holes in the floor
they can teleport in
no.2 in the peak my instincts around
that's disgusting
go Spencer you might have to press right
left control to place the bar holes down
don't give them tips a bottle we sound
so angry Disney sounds angry
yes I think I lost you by the way so
yeah well good luck to them I don't
we're a new team there are no wait oh
okay I'll be lookout I mean like we can
do both at the same time okay I'm
getting very confused that's right we're
at we're a squad now squad oh is the
guys the strange of things killer isn't
it Oh get here from across the map oh my
gosh haven't made it blow up yet I'm
very happy I'm very proud of you Thanks
we might even get one generator done Oh
bollocks run away oh that's okay he's on
brain go means we got a chance to run
plated I believe in you I don't all you
need is the power of friendship
oh he's sound so angry
oh my god I've already played against
this killer like one time one generation
baby
okay we gotta get we've gotta help
Raiden
two times in a row I think you say the
corpse you gotta you gotta press
spacebar to pick them up I'm going this
the way Oh
walkies now wait wait yeah
wait okay Big Crunch but I'm on a hook
okay this stream can be remembered in
the annals of history as oh he's a
company yeah so hey jammy bastard
I wasn't camping no oh no I'm scared
bold I mean what I forgot everything
[Laughter]
please leave me alone
Jordan
saws guys I've got rid of one of the
buttholes later
nice to balls down oh yeah right
Rob wait stay crouched oh my god it
right away
wait if you wiggle enough oh my god
you're giving me away hear me I forgot
your back saucepan alright start if
you're on the floor Jordan you're being
an [ __ ]
Braden you're gonna die yeah say away
yes no no I don't I kind of find them
no okay watch where you're going bugs
you come towards us savers yes what wait
what one of you is telling me to stay
away you're telling me the car might be
trying to redirect you so that you know
you don't come and you don't give me the
position away I thought I could save
myself hey buddy hey no you can so you
can you can recover yourself to 99%
basically come on let's go for a walk
yeah it saved me I believe in you Brady
no that was the opposite of saving me
okay
I see what you mean coin yes
I was literally I stood right in front
of Braden as he died
[Music]
I'm just crawling around I merely
wiggled out and then has murdered every
single II did I might destroy in where's
your corpse I'm not a coach I can't my
boride left you that's cuz I've moved my
screen like a little red slug okay sound
like I'm gonna hide here cuz I don't
think he walked over me last time I was
somewhere like this very inconvenient
[Laughter]
clean up IV seek I just wish I would
stop like whimpering cuz that's really
annoying yeah not realistic [ __ ] not
for bad our Savior it might be my fault
that everyone in the chasm has bleeding
is right now I apologize I get I get
excited
oh no no it's my scream I feel like I
screamed maybe it was entitled maybe
it's all of us
now you suggest me now there's like at
least three other people like crap at
this after I'm dead my defeat well I
can't find any blood Amy's Amy's gonna
bleed out now that's why it makes you
lose committing I'll just show them good
job yeah
you aren't she really good usually don't
play the killer like really bad so one
of the one of the perks that I
recommended in that list earlier hmm is
barbecue and chili which is is is what
Jordan had on every time you hook one of
the survivors you can see all of the
other survivors that are far enough away
you also had a monitor and abuse on
which changes your screen so it changes
your field of vision whenever there's a
survivor knee so it's like a bit more
obvious when they when they're when
they're nearby yeah good stuff well
plate I tried really hard to make sure
you would survive Braden it's fine I
[Music]
maybe was on the ground and I'm
definitely gonna try and stay and just
just here with thanks again ELISA Mendez
it's a group effort on perforated ears
it's a very it's a career right he was
up next he wants to kill now autumn art
yeah final but deadly yep
like a bad thought like a bad father a
far the best fat we have different
opinions I suppose if you're on the
receiving end it's different so those in
chat those in chat who are asking what
to do how to win the survivors need to
repair five generators in total which
will power the exit gates which you can
then open and leave ours in that game we
we beat the previous record we got to
them
did we actually get to I think it was -
I wish there was like an easy version
where you could start at 3 and then up I
feel really awful wait now I feel like
I'm really awful done yeah ok and you
did blow up the same time I blew up
I did I did I did I got I managed to
fail every generator check I did last oh
it's very tense there I'm gonna change
my cage I forgot I had the bright red
t-shirt on the stuff that's kind of
giving me away a little bit it's only
play Feynman Fang min is an eSports
player that's her backstory she play
these sports
so what she doing out here then well so
the the the kind of concept behind this
game is that everyone's been pulled into
this weird purgatory of just constantly
dying and being reborn and dying and
being reborn oh so it's not this isn't a
real life place this is this isn't like
she got bored playing video games and
decided to go into the woods to die like
killer robot right in for the kill
you'll never hit right I'm coming
exterminate Oliver great infection 2020
Eliseo said with a super chat according
on twitch not on on YouTube saying if
it's that hard $100 if you get all five
generators oh my god thank you for the
birthday wishes jozek and everyone else
oh and you in the pink to the rescue get
up I'll get those generators by your
level Tom I played this game a lot
well most to be found most of my games I
am is probably playing with friends in
lobbies like leaves
I like this we should do this again
those it's fun yes one I thought it's
gonna be more terrified I wouldn't I
want Tom to play like play like you're
found killer awesome I've got a couple I
got a couple of our Dean voices for but
I wanted I didn't want to start off on a
high you name you were like Australian
guy he was just kind of annoyed about
was barbecue it's just fun yeah I did
the whole I did the whole angry thing
that's the whole angry thing time grief
imagine the purgatory is dead by
daylight forever hey it's a good game
alright okay he has been behind you I
should be with someone
oh hello hello oh great it's you
Steve Harrington to the rescue let's go
blow up some generators oh we're on TV
sports everything of games what is this
so there's there's one killer there's
one killer he's no silent killer he
called me a [ __ ] bastard so this
guy's called the trapper he put straps
on the ground Jordana if you see bear
traps on the ground don't stand on the
bear traps no promises but I mean kind
of into that kind of thing so just bear
traps go in bear traps
amen don't disturb radios iodized is so
terrifying he called me a [ __ ]
bastard right no that's silent oh but
I'm not
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
around yes oh wow its Samaria those
smell the peach or coming down my legs
Oh bollocks
I'm scared young man if you could still
Thursday where are you
by the building no no I can just see you
pacing around Braden it's because I was
hiding behind a tree the whole time
ideals I was doing that thing where you
walk around so they can't see that's
rather unfortunate isn't it it's a
little bit [ __ ] yeah okay
[ __ ] thank you sir oh you've got a
first-aid kit you you really even use
your first-aid goes oh wait I should
probably Amy I mean anyone can you feel
me even oh okay great great
guys it's like all the most though I
thought most of the way through the
generator right me save me yes you need
to go save one of the three of us
I have a first-aid kit he's got there I
think he might have the nurses cooling
perk on which lets you see when you're
healing yourself I feel like he's coming
guys she's coming right away I don't
know where I'll go Aaron I'm gonna go in
here he's mine gave me you here what are
the people of the floor I'm hiding I
should probably go healing what if you
guys though
Oh God it's your turn now
you're not having a hit good game this
time are you okay oh my god I was so
close how do I do it
do I just click my button he's going to
you he's gonna tease give it to you
right right away run away oh my god I'm
so scared
how do you feel about eSports yeah cool
cool I don't know click click to shoot
right click to shoot head shots shots
I'm so proud that I've saved someone you
want to repay the food so Amy's dead
unfortunately wave to work for her lines
we're for health now we're good ok
oh he's kicking the generator I fix
I think Braden's the creepiest killer
just saying I mean I like the thing
about how you could smell me that was
pretty good so if you're on the floor
and you're waiting for someone to save
you you know the hold mouse one to
slowly recover your health so Noreen am
oh he's he's biting guys for example oh
no lady was to have lost you Ria's son
after Amy Epson chat for Amy herself
scared yep that was just what I did
mmm-hmm
oh yeah it's creepy any yeah hope
someone said trap off house mate I've
actually seen some people stand in their
traps on purpose just to make it to pick
them up and moving Oh Jordan you sir are
the worst yes this is my second time on
the hood keep pressing spacebar it
didn't have to be better what happens if
you skip a single beat you should have
skipped a beat
sorry guys I'm okay my first time on the
hook so I'm okay for a little bit the
art be everyone sometime if it's like
doing the pinks alpha trap and wrist
Cornelia said he's hooked on two in the
pink
don't [ __ ] ow oh that's very
unfortunate
[Music]
oh I can hear ya mi talking so much now
that you can't hear and we keep talking
keep talking keep talking you don't be
able to hear anything there we go
I'm Blu genomic you know oh I don't know
way to me wait why are you Irish now no
I was just about to get up Natasha stop
okay now I need to start off what's very
hard to get around without a first aid
kit or anything
Bradon how do you feel about East Falls
I'm dead Oh
rips find the hatch I'm gonna try and
find the hatch oh yeah destroy one of
his totems I don't know which one it was
so what it was a very easy can't use
anymore so it was a totem with the with
a scandal on it did have a count vomit
no just a skull yes if it's got can
plummet there's got one of his perks if
it doesn't then it's just a waste of
time it's just a it's just a thing okay
I didn't know that that's right
it's a learning experience Annette told
me i'mma tell you your accent I keep
like watching people from doorways and
stuff and I get like very homesick huh
connection lost how'd you get kids yeah
that's why the game is still going on
give you a play-by-play and all they buy
play so fast is that play by play is
that people in discord keep giving Tom
away oh I could hear something moving
around there
can you oh I'm gonna game okay but okay
wait I guess I'll just talk to you guys
we can have a little time of our and
while they're playing I'll let them I'll
ask them to let me on that day
I got kicked so now you guys have me all
to yourselves to talk to you as you can
see not big in this game but it's all
about fun and I mean you just did it
because I wanted to hear Tom's voices
Braden was quite funny as we gather I
think as I've done the killer ones as
well and I absolutely suck as the killer
so I just there's just no hope for me
unity 5 trailer is amazing I was
wondering when we were gonna see that
where you unity 5 or you took my Unreal
Engine 5 because that one was so good I
was like how how did they manage that up
so many triangles choking on my own
excitement how do they manage to have so
many triangles and it was all
dynamically less as well and like the
models there are multiples of them just
imported straight from um ZBrush without
having any normal Maps I was like what
how excuse me it was very impressive
it's all about the concept exactly as I
see oh it's all about the content and
you enjoy your briefly so far so good
questions all Milanovic well I did I
work today
but yeah it was good I got Harleen from
my housemate and her partner and I do
have some presents to open up I've
actually got Amy's present but I'm
guessing with probably I'm probably
gonna open that one up tomorrow because
we have our third live stream tomorrow
so yeah I've got that and then my mum
did give me a quick phone call just
before this livestream side that's why I
was running a little bit late I was like
oh I'm getting ready for a live she was
like oh it's my mum come on it's my mom
and she was on she was in the car and
she was just like talking to me like I
can't hear you she's like how's the
weather you know typical mum stuff did
you poke your capture card yes I did the
capture cards all ready to use tomorrow
morning
I had a little play with it and it
should be good to go
it was pretty easy to set up actually so
yeah you'll get to see that tomorrow oh
I've got an invite are they done already
if said that was very quick oh they're
done already
okay you guys wow that was so quick wait
let me put on my headphones that was
super quick or Braden's are excellent
killer damn
well I sorry I don't know if he caught
on stream but there was a moment where I
was kind of stood still and he wrapped
around my locations super close like
five times
mm-hmm then I snuck away to a closet but
I sprinted on the way there how did you
know I was in the closet
I guess because you said yes the supreme
sea lions disappeared sprint length well
played oh I have to pick up my Parks
again I forgot what I had mm-hmm Oh am I
to kill it now I guess I'll let you guys
actually win one game
I'm really glad killer believed in you
know I'm such a bad killer although I
did play what's my play last time it was
that lady that I didn't move yeah the
Huntress oh she was worse no no the
nurse sorry she is she is the worst oh
yes don't don't use the nurse she's
pretty terrible which ones are good many
of the other ones although if you play
the race I will be very upset with you
because I hate the way very much it got
to the point when we play when we play
against my friends now like I will just
be like if I if they pick the rate I
will just Rachel bet I did you know I'm
just like why do because so he can just
go visible and I think that's [ __ ]
but apparently I'm the only person in
the world who thinks that's [ __ ]
none of my friends hate him as much as I
am he makes my blood boil oh I can't be
owned I can be the race but you won't
because you love me very much
very good friends okay fine this one
what does this one mean you'll find out
oh no
oh but it's it's intermediate difficulty
how does it mean [ __ ]
are you sure because the nurse is hard
so this makes sense why I mean to read
the Reaper abilities at least he's
trying to bait me with money I can't be
good at this happy birthday your [ __ ] no
JK orange lights to me all right click
yeah yours right clear can you point
them at someone's fate at the killer's
face for long enough it will blind them
but for the most part of the killer can
just like look away so [ __ ] it I'll just
see what this one does
happy birthday to you yes
happy birthday to you yes happy birthday
[Music]
first aid kit this time because last
time I could have gone away a bunch of
times but I didn't I couldn't heal
myself yet don't rely on any of us not
worse yahzee opening up yeah well I
guess so cuz it's only really yours
isn't it so we might as well do that on
a string okay use the character that Tom
hates and get twenty dollars betray my
friendship this is my own fault
[Music]
I'm more than welcome to play the Wraith
I'm not gonna have to give you anoint I
mean I do hate the Wraith but if you
have to
lots of debates I don't have any a bunch
of free ones the wraith is a free one
night yes look see it's on your level
fifty how many blacks do using this time
me I think you should just pack up and
I'm using one popular I mean I I mean I
could but it's just I'm bringing I'll
bring I'll bring an item instead I've
got one part I'll bring an eye on
someone Lana Vic's like gas is too
kind-hearted to be a good killer that's
why I'm an angel
I'm staying quiet stuck in my [ __ ]
head now about dying
it's fine you'll birthday soon so I'll
be stuck in your head again and we'll
sing it to you this time I'll believe it
when I hear it
yep Brayden sing to us oh I have tried
to make everything for me so many times
I can relate to that what if we just do
the north happy birthday - yes and
Brayden chimes in yes please so thirty
dollars from Elise you know if you say
okay yes three dollars for me not to
sing
onion spring onion can you do it proper
Jenner accent what do you mean right me
lover my today night bird for the
greater good
last carnage that was close enough
that's probably great you're good job
great records I love you know me out
bloody dare you someone just asked if
this is those cops carry on yes this is
Shannon I am actually Scottish so am I
I love how this just type with like
brain and sing onion and then we just
take it off everyone in the chest
let's go squid goo like I can't find
these packs that you've put in the lava
buzzing oh but even color based are the
open no it's separated by so other your
purple ones that you put in the chat
I think we're killing people in the chat
cuz they're all dying of laughter SARS
yes but for real they go go wraiths cuz
they'll be funny too I'll be fun to
watch wise will you're screaming terror
actually comes through the wall to
murder us all so if you play right now
they're less likely to have people
playing the Wraith again in the future
because I think if you're raced you have
to have a downer accent the whole time
wait how do you like yours your special
ability they come up on the screen
yeah it's use usually is either
right-click or left control depending on
your by the way are there any different
levels Maps my level yeah we've been on
to do someone's already where we same to
me to their they do so you can use you
can use offerings to pick a map or since
I'm hosting the lobby I could I could
pick one for you I'll pick it up a come
out for us do you have a favorite yeah
but I've also got a lot that I hate and
it would be nice to be able to avoid
those I think I think I've never I've
got strong opinions about a lot of this
I think you guys will appreciate this
one I think you'll like it
oh my god everyone's like a breeding
farm in the chat
look he's having nothing Braden Braden
hashtag was God if you love so much
won't you just [ __ ] marry him
thinking words he was supported goods
what's a good names people who are fans
of Braden onions salt smoke slows a poor
night's excess of praises an agent of
your life agent 47 trying to be an agent
no where's the bold head why you did say
you're gonna shave your hair off maybe
soon you also get in the the lockdown Oh
like this map oh bloody yeah no I do
it's the stranger things man come back
wait who's the other come back Oh fix it
can I do it as well Oh bullets
well great gonna leave this one for you
right well done guys
I'll stay out loud I'm ready how do I do
this oh I've got to do this right okay
you guys are lucky I don't know where
the [ __ ] I'm doing okay so I mean yes
I'm frightened
is she playing the rain oh yeah me where
the [ __ ] did you go oh no no I'm not
though I'll let you guys know she's
playing Rachel when I when I see ya
I'm she is she's playing the right she
was a bloody like thank you Father
she's the right thing okay you you thank
you do you know how to use your
abilities properly yes
I can't you can only do that's just
right click to go invisible right click
to be invisible again
this is not fair there's step people on
the floor and I think it's you guys well
that self-inflicted right how do I pick
you up
wah-wah spacebar is this what the reason
is the race is only goes invisible we're
invisible splishy-splash oh [ __ ] Braden
Claire listen be patient okay to do
[Laughter]
where the [ __ ] do you guys go when you
go up here I guess so confused tell Anu
the perfect escape plan
I hate you
take a show wait I'm just going around
in circles here oh I need to urinate
sorry Alfie Errol no I just I'm confused
oh no no no it's cool yes would you
kindly piss off don't you go
disappearing on me now at least you came
through with the $50 tip are you playing
the rape food I tried to escape you be
proud of me oh wait please donate $50
because you play the rain now watch me
kill Amy ahahaha why you what else how
to kill me I don't know you're just
there all the time
rated rated R Jesus Christ
oh wait maybe dying guys at least you
know wait why are we going down here hey
wait wait Amy wait
oh those done well look at this check
out my whole that's a big hole thank you
wait are we going good man yeah oh oh
you guys be where could you guys be
where could you guys be if you ask for
time I might tell you where could you be
oh no I forgot I hear generators buttons
see generators are you generators oh
yeah you hear them why I'm hearing yeah
here this is the one that Braden [ __ ]
up on today that's pretty good
right now she's around here am i where
are you go to the team guys already been
killed twice it's fine
No where the [ __ ] are you welcome oh
yeah only two left folks told you I was
part of this
there is a game oh my god
burn away burn away burn away run away
Oh [ __ ] lost you there's too many
I want open spaces okay I should not
have got oh oh no oh no run run who are
you saying run - happy birthday to you I
know you're around here somewhere okay
I saw ya I'm like I'm not even here I'm
off playing eSports I'm like mega lost
oh wait wait who was that then I saw so
where is everyone
I saw jump down the hole she's
discovered the pink guys do you not use
that trick
oh she's found the hole yes not not your
whole another hole yeah
yours this still a secret I told you I'd
kill Amy an icicle
a new sports person you played every
[Laughter]
where the [ __ ] did you go girlishness
Papa okay
what thank you much nothing what what
what she doesn't seem to know about it
did not this one I think I went the
wrong way this time I will not let you
out of my grasp you all not escape me
where are my hooks now I'm wiggling damn
she's a savage though right come on guys
I want to kill Braden X he came into me
wait how do you say that aiming by the
way he's in exam in the direction that
you ran away okay
Minami alien egg men amenities uh no no
no men and mini mini
I won't can't don't why I'm not Eliseo
so you're gonna be Killer Queen
yeah yeah once you kill us although you
all hail me wait let me let me just
dispose of this trash no oh [ __ ] how
I keep losing me oh there you are
let me see the door No
where did he [ __ ] go we empowered the
gates we can now open the gates I leave
I don't know where the gates are Oh
Tom's gonna light up by the way where's
the K so when you first do these
generators they light up but they then
kind of fade away a little bit
oh wait where the [ __ ] did you go hey
they put something like right in front
of its [ __ ] face where is the rest of
you I know you'll be heading for that
door no I know where the door is no oh
[ __ ]
where the [ __ ] wait it's Braden God no
no well no in that case I'm taking him
hostage oh I think she is a Kirk Wiebe
dojo Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe I was
loving he was killer yes
I couldn't be more specific because
otherwise I'd ruin everything
sorry guys I did the key cards but there
was no hope you're away come on you can
find the girl I don't know where to go
but for reasons oh yeah you don't care
about me oh my god you guys working all
the time let me hear God send out of a
portrayals Jordan is an absolute mag
lads agree a man oh my god wait that was
I was at the other door waiting for you
ah oh that was so good
I told you I'm not very good as the
killer you did well you did pretty well
Jenny
I'll be back oh you got the [ __ ]
all-seeing room you know me you bastard
I made life easy for myself I'm also
gonna pay so I'm just gonna put the
stream on the Beemer secular Pig
okay let's have a pee break em I'm brave
yeah everyone else get up and stretch
all right everyone's watching
pee break we'll be right back
you
you
hey I see you are talking about the
image that Nikki drew I think the
blanket is because it is my bedsheets
I've got these bed sheets I bet you got
them on now and they've got little stars
on them and they glow in the dark cuz
you know I'm 10 years old
anyway get back to whit
oh oh I've been kicked as well all right
guys I'm gonna undef Aneesa don't be
saying anything to embarrass them Baker
[Music]
hey can the Queen well I was gonna oh
yeah yeah yeah I think I've been kicked
I think y'all havin no oh I told me that
I had game is Braden still there yeah
okay good just checking someone's
missing let's cuz he hasn't still
assigned to kill her when she goes back
to survival and hope you're right so
who's gonna kill next then I'm slated to
kill next Thomas day oh yeah you gonna
do when your what do you avoid tell ya
you've picked up too much now everything
surprises
[Music]
okay okay all right now you guys know
what you're doing I'm kicking up to two
pugs
oh yeah totes know what I'm doing we're
basically professionals well knew that
already
Braden is plotting yes he was Nikki
plotting for when he max gets to murder
everyone for New York man so I'm just
looking at my party parks who is a 40
years old
Congrats my oldest friends baby
zero four zero disgusting go back on I
love having friends what's right oh I
paid for you all to be here tonight okay
the play against my friends tonight
Craigslist
Tasha players race for vengeance by NECA
thank you so much for your amazing
generosity tonight Jesus Christ honestly
made my birthday like better thank you
and is Killer Queen in the loud squad is
that what we are now
I think I like that okay I'm still
choosing my last pack I'm ready sorry
I'm taking forever that's okay you're
old forget it yeah I think my eyesight
is going I'm not wearing my glasses
right now I have glasses
[Laughter]
I have graphic like my mom whenever
whenever I'm like mom read this she's
like oh wait no this is dad's glasses I
don't have multiple glasses yet but it
will go that way one day one day so I
got my I got my face master today like
yeah to go out into the real world with
yeah oh yeah and it's a [ __ ] issue
getting around with glasses and having
one of them on oh my god honestly a
[ __ ] two steps out the door and
they'll [ __ ] up oh I'm super
short-sighted so if I'd been like Tesco
whatever and I'm looking around I'm like
I'm gonna like put my face up I take my
glasses off so I guess themed I've got
my face I know my um my coworker made me
a chicken mask I saw and they wore it
out but like I you get weird looks when
you wearing them it's like it's okay
it's allowed like I wish more people
would I think England just doesn't have
the mass culture I've had people like
see me wearing my mask so then they put
their like jumpers over their mouths but
just when they're passing me and I'm
like do you think I've like I'm ill like
I don't know well yeah I mean you can
use them to like protect others from
your stove yeah yeah but yeah the Q is
my god
oh when we play with his friend Jenny
she hates this this is the one when I
watched all the clips
let me wittle by Billy for you hmm
Oh bollocks sorry guys we forgot to
wiggle then I was too distracted by how
frickin horrifying here's is he the bad
do we have two new friends no I'm alone
god damnit oh are you crying or laughing
the thing okay let's be pals that's not
gonna work on me oh my god I'm so scared
of you
I mean our our painful why does nobody
hard at these covers like your brother's
pretty well I like your hater did you
get it
you got none no no it's fine a special
look for you what this one now that's
our special hook I got a Christmas tree
oh that's awful um booty
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with these bottles
what a week oh okay guys I am going to
talk wait where is he gone
you're a kid Tom where are you it's
genève already okay a very specific
skillset it doesn't include engineering
what is it I'm gonna die you're lying
do you like my Wiggles terrifying yes
very
somebody's not very good at generators
kicky kicky why are you so good at this
no just like they could do friends
here's another little kid Kiki not in
here but I heard someone it's bringing
on the floor still where did I put him
[Laughter]
save yourself freedom
where the [ __ ] did I bring you please
keep making those funny those noises
noises oh those noises you make when
you're all the floor grown it like
you're making was so I get for trying to
be a hero
[ __ ] my way damn it yeah obviously it
scratch marks
that means friendship hmm the one time
yes is quite unique somewhat giant
Savior
right I'm your only real friend thank
you son it's like well if they get out
of it because you've deployed you
[ __ ] do it yes I'm right nothing
right to sacrifice you sacrificial onion
boy oh wait sorry I didn't realize being
the best of friends
Oh breathe again breathe
wait did you go up that's very nice of
you friends anytime now how's it going
let's be friends I don't want to be
friendship yeah come on here
do not be smell bad thanks booth
everybody Lots people who likes their
booths 'total stabby stabby
oh look behind you really [ __ ]
generous
oh yes yes yeah
we'll open up and it will make like a
wind gushing noise as pretty if I'm near
it yes okay I guess I'll just walk
around I believe in you thank you
well those days we friends we're all
getting along so well now they're Church
I'm listening for a hatch thanks
everyone who's giving us a shot I felt I
feel bad for brazen if someone's on the
floor you can heal them back up you
don't need it Medicare ID then you just
walk over to them from this Mouse one
and you'll heal them back - we never we
were healings we're healing each other
well then I rent to run to one of them
because I can't tell who's who and then
it was Amy so this is like I'll [ __ ] it
I'll just pick her up and then we
started the best choice I knew you far
away so I was like yeah I'm gonna do I
made it and then the next thing I know
you appeared in medicine literally never
seen it so that somebody is picked off
of the floor this is such low health but
the next time they get put down they
diary
to that point I think he's died at the
show he's just saying like - I think the
only reason it wouldn't have happened to
anyone else is because they would have
been very vocal about bleeding out
that's true that's actually really true
everybody you did good someone on it
yeah anammox said that you're great by
the way Tom thank you very much yes I
agree yeah also kind of don't want to be
a friend
listen I didn't murder you half as
quickly as the other guy's mother do you
shoot up here is it no Braden thanks
America someone I love except that he's
a fellow Braden onion layer Fredo neucom
followers for some reason they're called
onion lists
I need them but when they do it's it's
good do you have anything to say to your
newfound fellowship Braden fellowship
yeah well it's a fellowship we've got an
objective oh okay your newfound plan oh
okay
are you gonna say anything to them well
potatoes boil a mushroom sticker miss do
not changed from from from eSports we're
now doing metal Jesus teaching a
building voice that's all Jesus
oh that was good taters right I'm ready
oh my god some another big said you're
not a fellowship you're a layer [ __ ]
layers layers like a cake
I mean you are as tall as know how tall
six foot four does we think she's mad no
[Music]
oh come on Shrek isn't that much taller
than future should I check the DD
sourcebooks that'd be really help folks
we're doing DD soon oh we are doing
dandy yeah and Amy's a partner it's
going to be a dungeon master for us yeah
but he's been unplugging the Dragons for
like years with his no friends so yeah
it'll be fun it'll be a small campaign I
think Sylvia fat well it'll be my second
time playing D&D the first time I was a
princess wizard because I couldn't
decide to forward to be a princess or
wizard so I was both the source books
say that olgas are between nine and ten
feet tall well well yeah and they weigh
close to a thousand pounds shrek is not
nine foot tall I think he is No
donkey that's fine now he's quite old no
he's not a ninth birthday I am my new
pianist now hey he's not a D&D okay he's
just an ogre from a different face oh
just so everyone knows I am 5 foot 1 so
I am very small so dad fault
I do think that Braden is like massive
anyone above like 5 foot 8 is like a
massive joint you know ok so Shrek is 7
Rayden you are Fiona sighs she's also an
ogre
but she's Allah so you nothing wrong
with that
metal Jesus is here Jesus is ready wait
wait where's my friend
it's Jordan's time hello friends
what are you doing oh sorry I'm playing
with my hair
yeah no yes
use the hunters hunters can throw axes I
can see you have my ax
you are my art Oh gave it to us you
didn't give it back
you have my MA
you have my ax terrible I am so
frightened I mean it's your birthday
that's excellent good job
oh yeah you disgusting disgusting
disgusting
oh hello why are you torturing me come
and make the day like so bad I hate the
humming I love it
so cool they've also added some extra
voice lines so it's like she usually
hums but now she can hum and it sounds
like she's drunk
Wow they used to speak and now when she
does it sounds like [ __ ] I thought he
didn't see me wait who is the killer
Huntress it's Jordan Jordan why so quiet
you that's Kuwait dude is killing us
yeah Jordans the killer Oh
oh I lost you did you go no no this is
Mel Jesus you're looking for the wrong
person oh my god thank you dan vâlcea
thank you so much pad character
cheerfully blowing party [ __ ] horn
and I just blew up a generator no no no
but thank you Dad no stop it
Jordan oh my god
oh it's me oh my god oh my god damn it
Jordan
hey this hatchet throwing thing is
really useful yeah yeah I'm a wiggle
why if I got worse at this game so one
said people with the Scottish accent
can't say purple burglar alarm pressure
they do struggle we have a friend who's
got a really broad Scottish accent so we
used to make him say there's been a
murder with a curly wurly bugger damn it
Jordan we piss off thanks Braden I was
an onion now not congrats guys [ __ ] a
duck
[Music]
I think of all the the killers the
hunters would be the most bunch of
cosplayers oh I don't like it stop home
in dabit where are you leave me I didn't
think you'd see me is capade
[Music]
all the way around that way I've lost it
wait what why can I hear it from in
front of me oh wait jobs around thank
you so much : Williams I hope you're
having an awesome birthday I am Oh cute
okay I'm just walking into a walk so if
I keep the chair I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it for the team
with the were do it do it do it do it
now do it good brains under attack it
was a reason bar away someone could save
me and they would be safe for them to
save me
for [ __ ] sake listen I guess you guys
write quite proud of myself for hiding
from him in the first place you did well
thank you sir
if you had there's a perk called we'll
make it which means when you save
someone from a hook your healing speed
is doubled so take that on we probably
would have got out of that I'm probably
gonna die now but I will pick that Park
next time I think it's a good one I
pretty much don't play the game without
it okay even in a wicked it gave me um
no I knew I was gonna die straightaway
so didn't matter
oh that was your I didn't realize that
as you dead it's cave that's funny cause
you did only heal when you know these
faraway situations well
oh yeah just stock up on your axes yeah
yeah I can't go anywhere without my
hatchets
oh mama said
oh that good for killing Cir feeler
cakes I saved tom-toms actually good at
this game so I feel like it was worth it
yeah no you did usually good one plus
Jesus
so bonus points in half oh right you're
going back on this my face
wait what is this what just happened
that was like a ripple died through the
world Braden everyone loves you except
me
everyone everyone in the chat is like
except Jordan oh dayum hatchets your
hatchets away from him Chris Brandon's
being all mysterious a buddy time no no
this is tense
hmm Jesus is injured guys
Oh God the Father the Son the Holy
Spirit I pray for you Jesus where are
you why you and did you manage to escape
he's just distraction Braden is in
desperation was losing him he works in
mysterious ways yes you know that yeah
I'm Mel Jesus the og oh Jesus
let the bodies hit the floor
oh no I picked up a ship first aid kit
why did you do that because I wasn't
expecting it to be worse I do that to
you I I didn't even know he could do
that if you press our drop the urchin
that you're carrying so you no one told
me that well there's a lot of likes
towel I'm not it's just when I open them
boxes okay learning same you're not the
only one thing right I think I just need
to get better looking around
he's paid taking the game by a John baby
babes who you watching the pro tom ah
tricks I travel in a giant stream I've
got the stream on my phone and then on
my PC I've got a boom [ __ ] good one
good one yes I'm learning that was the
creepiest
[Music]
[Laughter]
last time I haven't been on the hook
yeah I don't think she's off the chain
if you know what I mean oh yes what what
you're on the hook do cut what the
generators yeah baby
no we didn't the doors not open where we
have that open the doors what you saying
I didn't know that they you have to pull
down the handle and wait for lights
never have I gotten this far before
on my own I just someone just says I
mean the doors are open and I just think
they've just happened magically oh I see
who do you usually play with randoms Tom
Oh Tom and his friends this door is
taking [ __ ] ages open this game is
like hide-and-seek basic city asteroids
you have to hold down the door like you
do the generators then Tom yeah it's
like a big leave oh this could take a
while then
damnit
I see what you did that we've ever been
so creepy children you can hear yourself
oh no aunt you another pie oh maybe you
feel like an add-on or something that
you do know apparently your scream was
really thou jazz sorry
it always sisters turn me down if you're
on the hope for the first time you go
slipways over yes you've got a 3% chance
of succeeding it's not worth and if you
do try yeah reduces the amount of time
that you can stay with you I don't know
3% it's like maybe 4 I think that it
goes up with the certain perks that you
can add and the offerings that you can
go on
[Music]
you guys just saw bound
fritzsche Cornelius says Jordan with the
convoys has a strange silence of the
lambs definitely he says yeah just Tom
now but when he climbs up to changes
agreed I think I prefer Jesus Tom to fan
Tom just saying I thought I watched you
leave you came back and check there and
both the jazz and I were hidden just
crouched waiting he walked up you stared
directly in my direction it took
everything in me to not say something
cause I usually sports I was a good game
well played John honestly
should we do like one more game just
because I want to be nice and rested for
tomorrow morning's livestream and we
might need to talk about that Amy as
well yeah we talked about sure who would
you like to be the killer then birthday
girls choice actually not me though
look see but not that much now I think
the problem is I think everyone wants to
see some more yeah scaling but we also
want to see some more Braden coming will
make your votes in the chat guys yeah
everyone vote for who should be the
killer for the last game I mean cuz
Tom's quite fun care to I've done plenty
of killing Wow serial killer over here
wants me to do it dance though right huh
you could do the Macarena and then how
does it go after that I mean your
shoulders and then your hips and then
you got a wiggle in jump we got so far
we've got a vote we've got is that to
brief you has to be the killer to me oh
gosh that's gonna be a long game we put
Janet I love that kristin is 5 a.m.
because it's because it's it's her
stream and it's her birthday
yeah that like it's so creepy but it
would be sad to miss out on a Braden
kiddo as well silent but deadly
we've lost Jordan
I've just said you've left the party
okay why did you leave us I can still
see Jordan wait wait Thomas was that
thing you said just stare at me you
should get rid like you say will make it
it's at add-ons no reserve Pope will
make it you see wait so who's being the
killer Neal Braden no it looks like most
of the votes of the ass okay well I'll
let you guys I'll let you guys win you
can't play and let us swim if you let me
win they'll all know it's fake
right see you you are yeah dude oh can
you not leave please welcome actually
got lost again
I trained you again don't know what's
going on that's the game the games a bit
funky mate don't worry about it you want
to open that bright yes yes yes I'm
bunny open a window you want an open
kind of man oh yes please okay I mean I
was probably just making excuses before
but yeah I got lost in the stranger
things man yeah I know it was actually
quite confusing to be honest it is it is
a bit of a confusing map but also it's
fun because it's stranger things you
know and it was cool to see you guys
have like your little hidey holes and
then mean land the tricks behind this
hidey holes and then I could exploit
huge secret
I feel like I showed you that I'm very
sorry he did I like I watched you come
out of it and then I watched you go up
and then jump down again
- I wouldn't be down the bottom Tilly
visible probably okay I guess I should
try a different killer then not the
nurse why is she suck yes you should be
the nurse I think they hope they have
just changed it so she didn't used to be
that slow but like she has a blinker
Bertie where he teleports a short
distance but it's really hard to use
yeah yeah this one can't be that but
that wasn't that was cool what you don't
have the clown husband they've done a
good room yeah but but yes when you'd
have to calm I don't have there was the
clown yes man what are you yes me be the
clown so you'd have the clown yes maybe
you should get the clown you should do
you should do a clown voice I don't I
don't I need to be me I shouldn't you
know you can be the rain with you on no
don't be the Wraiths I hate the rape the
Wraiths is awful
yeah I missed Tom on that one thank you
if were nice sexism be Harley Quinn -
man I got Harleen today Tom I saw I've
been even employed and I said I'm very
jealous because I every time I tried to
go out and find it I can never find
vol.1 oh well you can find out on Amazon
it's quite cheap on that
yeah I'm sorry good but also I forget
I can't ring I did what you can select
an offering you know why can't you
select an offering okay no it just makes
a squelching noise and nothing happens
are you selecting no it just won't let
me go into the page just oh wait why buy
a Jordan I feel like the less of a noob
now it's so nice like I haven't spoken
to Jordan I haven't spoken to you since
Christmas
mmm but no bad friend yeah you are shady
you think you so salty though oh there
are only three issues I know that I knew
that they were like bigger issues a
current issue one for this Harlequin
comic it's it's drawn by like one of my
favorite comic artists yeah I think we
were talking about this last time I saw
you in it yeah yeah wait didn't you meet
me after that yes date in Miami day oh
my oh yeah I remember that I remember so
she's got to me on three I remember oh
my god maybe we should all have like a
big date with all of us
so this batch wait on me no indecisive
have a chicken soup shop date I don't
know if that would work
probably not
I like dumb chickens but not everyone
does you know yeah it's difficult with
the vegans and veggies the V goes in the
veg the veg heads okay Wow I was just
calling to you I think we don't you in
that clown outfit oh no we said not
everyone likes chicken yes you can get a
veggie nuts like nope nuts yes I had
those at Weatherspoon's they were very
good they're really good and I don't
really like my spoons oh I had a little
while back I had temple of Satan hot
wing things BrewDog I think it was
BrewDog was super super super super
super good although we made a mistake
because it was like okay vegan Tuesday's
on the [ __ ] so you could buy one get
one free and we didn't think about it so
we just bought one of these huge sharing
plan
is thinking oh well just get a big one
and then it doubles every things fine
there's no killer here we're just a
bunch of engineers out on the job okay
like is the worst kind of hoping that it
would just pop up and be like you
survived yes oh dear that was a fast
generator it was it's always my favorite
every single check same I was very proud
of myself are you proud of yourself Amy
are you proud of yourself
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
god damn it why am I so bad at this game
oh my god oh my god two generators just
blowing up around their trap thank you
sir
oh my god this I can't believe you only
oh wait how many traps do I get so you
can pick up one our time unless you have
an ad on the
pick up two there on the floor all over
the map you should be able to see them
can I do something to this generator
it's current lying repaired if it's like
not quite full then yes you can press
spacebar to kick it if it's full and
done turned on he turns around with it
where the [ __ ] - jeez dude oh no I I
stepped in my own trap right it doesn't
kill you it kills us
well dammit that wasn't me for once
Oh No Jesus Jesus Jesus that's
mathematics to you I am NOT a believer
you know believe in the metal Jesus a
Mountie see you later
he's so good at that escape it though
it's unreal escapade I really hate
chasing him I don't think I've hated
chasing any of your hands
it's a skilled do was skin you oh oh I
think you guys are gonna win this one
it's the sweetest thing oh my god
wait what I just saw someone here I've
lit what the [ __ ] you just disappeared
in hello is anyone that way I'm like a
fear of Australians now just nightmares
oh she said she's sitting off her own
traps GW bro I'm about to kick one
machine yeah well if I can kick
everything I was doing so well we go I'm
wiggling yeah okay
your husband's on me if you want to
maybe go save Amy so quick and there's a
trap in the way there I did not see that
trap at all oh okay thank you
oh my god my legs
wait fine no swearing on my stream
please this is PG [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I definitely wouldn't things together I
mean unless you're just trying to brag I
don't even know which one just exploded
damn
that's just good engineering it is hello
oh hello
please leave I know what you're doing
you're just trying to get me I'm lost
[Laughter]
oh my god I didn't think I'd actually be
with Tom could have actually got I mean
you became Arvin okay well I guess thank
you so much for watching us and
we're gonna call it a night now so
everyone and if you just want to say
goodbye to the chats goodbye Oh smells
like one too
[Laughter]
hippo character applauds well it's not
being in approval saying Gigi I love
that restream doesn't actually show me
like any of the emotes it just explains
what we are so just so you guys know do
not forget we have one last birthday
stream and that's gonna be tomorrow at
10:30 a.m. PST and it's gonna be a me
and I Amy hi live I guess like morning
show
thank you Michael a slice of pink
birthday cake with purple icing and I
kinda alright is another thing I know he
was telling me what I smelled like well
you definitely don't smell like I know
can't confirm and she does not smell
like that you guys haven't seen me in a
long time you don't know my smell might
have changed it lady must you know I'm
just like AJ okay Toby hit menopause at
this point right 40 then you start
rude dry it's a level 40 in the park you
get to pick his your fragrance so I
prefer to talk to animals but you know
I'll take it
yeah thank you so much for watching I
will see you tomorrow bright and early
well not really that bright and early
but 10:30 a.m. PST oh and cuz it's gonna
be an animal crossing I am gonna send
out a dodo code beforehand for people to
come and visit my little island and you
can actually be like in with us in the
livestream so from from when to when I
don't know well for now 10:30 a.m. the
ft until I don't I don't bloody know
until we get borage guys okay I've got
some powers I might send them your away
but all right thanks Tom treat me every
time I speak to you and the occasional
Janice lip comes out hmm yo your accent
is like flawless until every now and
again oh my god thank you again my god
it is appreciated my couple slice of
onion with it oh wait that's braid of
this birthday layers huh you can have a
second I'm having a second birthday this
year just saw him Oh what out outside of
quarantine yeah I'm happy to being the
Queen this year so I got a second
birthday where it can actually celebrate
outside good
you're invited Oliver Vitus and no
officer Naruto I didn't get a birthday
cake me
oh yeah it's already Gary offices I'm
gonna Gary like to the pub yeah tense I
just have a quick coaching Tamaki's oh
yeah I see yeah okay I'm sorry
it always takes me so long to say
goodbye so I'm gonna say goodbye to who
I can see in the chat you guys can like
leave or stay in till the very end it's
up to you guys what measure exists hey
cuz big chatting after mm-hmm well I'll
probably phone you afterwards cuz I
actually still need to have dinner
oh okay you need sustenance but yeah
thank you so much for watching I hope
you guys had a good time so by dre and
dog by Officer Naruto quite some dynamic
by kid Phantom goodbye I just I just got
a flashback to like phantom phantom he's
defensive isn't that with Danny Phantom
yes sure sure thing what didn't watch it
um goodbye trained dog by Samuel otter
goodbye Samuel laughing I mean not
having any cake goodbye Christian give I
soul all kids and yes it is ending
goodbye Fritz Cornelius goodbye a la a
blue several goodbye but a little it 196
Danny Phantom bear your parents you get
it thank you
Priscilla and goodbye mantas goodbye so
Manovich and my body
probably already said that okay and
goodbye to anyone that I haven't seen in
the chat and goodbye to everyone
watching who isn't in the chat we still
appreciate you being here as well so
thank you very much for spending your
evening with us do you guys wanna say
goodbye all right guys it's fun
sometimes but ye